SAAD ALI: Hello, everyone.
I'm here at KubeCon Seattle.
My name is Saad Ali.
I'm hosting today's activities.
I have Brian Grant over here.
Brian has been with
the Kubernetes project
from the very beginning.
He's got a very long list
of titles that I have here.
He is the co-tech lead of Google
Kubernetes Engine, the co-chair
of the Kubernetes Native
Special Interest Group
for SIG Architecture,
Kubernetes API approver.
He is also on the Kubernetes
Steering Committee.
And he is part of the CNCF
Technical Oversight Committee.
Brian, you've been with the
project for a very long time.
Can you talk about
where it all started
and where we've come since?
BRIAN GRANT: Yeah, I've
been at Google 11 years.
At this point, I feel
like I've been working
on this project for 10 years.
I worked on Google's internal
container platform, Borg,
before this, and founded the
Omega projects internally.
And we talk about Kubernetes
being an open-source Borg.
It's actually closer to
being an open-source Omega,
because a lot of the ideas
were inspired by ideas that we
developed further in Omega.
And some of them, we
integrated back into Borg.
And others were hard
to integrate into Borg.
Around 2013 when Docker
really started to take off,
we had started to work on
open-sourcing our own container
runtime.
Let me contain that for you.
And when we saw Docker
really had a much better user
experience, we were
a lot more focused
on resource utilization.
We're going to talk about
this more in our keynote
this afternoon with Tim
Hockin and Clayton Coleman,
so I won't give too
much away there.
But it was immediately
obvious to us
that this would be really
useful to the world broadly.
And there had been some
other open-source projects
in this area, like Mesos.
But we had some different
ideas about what
we wanted to do that
were, again, inspired
by our learnings from
Borg and our work on Omega
that we thought would be
really valuable to people.
So we started work on
the API design late 2013.
Eventually, the open-source
project took off.
We open-sourced it.
The initial project
just had four APIs--
pod, replication
controller, service, and I
want to say minion.
The endpoint API didn't
even exist yet, I think.
But we knew there would
be more and more APIs.
Borg also started with a
handful of resource types,
but it wasn't as extensible.
So we really ran into obstacles
trying to add new concepts,
for example.
So we wanted Kubernetes to have
at least an extensible concept
space where you could
create new resource
types for new concepts.
So it wasn't actually super
extensible in the beginning.
You had to extend
it with Go code.
And that's where we
partnered with the Red Hat
folks, who were building
OpenShift based on Kubernetes.
And we decided, at the
time, we would just
use in-process Go interfaces
as extensions for admission
control, for example,
for authentication
and authorization and for
resource implementations.
But over time, we've
converted those
to out-of-process
extension mechanisms,
like admission webhooks,
custom resource definitions,
API aggregation, and so on.
SAAD ALI: Do you think--
BRIAN GRANT: And that
was really motivated
by a lot of that internal
work at the beginning where
we were really lacking
those mechanisms.
SAAD ALI: Do you
think that's what
led to the project's success?
If not, what else do you
think was a part of--
BRIAN GRANT: I think that
was a big part of it.
We knew that just the ability
to launch and scale containers
was table stakes.
That was the bare minimum.
But people would need
a lot more than that.
And indeed, it's expanded
into a portable cloud platform
with more than 60
APIs, at this point.
So you can look
at cloud providers
and see all the different
services that they provide.
And people want a
portable version of that
that they can run in
a consistent fashion
in any environment.
And Kubernetes
provides that to them.
So as people try to adapt
Kubernetes to more and more use
cases, they add more features.
They also make it
more pluggable.
As you know-- you've been
working on the storage
systems--
how many different storage
layers there are, right?
So the more different
kinds of environments
and underlying infrastructure
that Kubernetes can run on,
the more broadly useful it
is, the bigger the community
and the bigger the ecosystem.
And that has a synergistic,
virtuous cycle effect
where more people are
invested in adding value
to the ecosystem as a whole.
SAAD ALI: So it
sounds like being
more extensible from the
beginning helped the project
become more successful.
Are there any
challenges associated
with trying to make the
project more and more modular?
BRIAN GRANT: Yeah.
So we have extension points in
a lot of places, at this point.
We have CSI, CNI, CRI
at the node level.
We also have the admission
hooks, admission authorization
hooks, authentication hooks.
We have custom resource
definitions, API aggregation.
So there are so many
different ways you can extend,
and people swap out
whole components as well.
People have swapped
out kube-proxy;
the scheduler; ingress,
obviously; autoscalers.
So making Kubernetes
work similarly enough
that people can get that
consistent environment
that they value is a challenge.
So this is why we started
the conformance program,
to help ensure API
compatibility and workload
portability across all
the different Kubernetes
distributions.
I think we have about 70,
now, Kubernetes distributions
and services that have
demonstrated that they
can pass the conformance test.
And we're actively working on
improving the conformance test
coverage for the things that
everybody uses and depends on,
especially for the
things that are highly
pluggable in the
system, because that's
where behaviors are likely to
deviate from one or another.
SAAD ALI: And for
those who aren't
familiar with the
conformance program, what
is the end benefit to users?
BRIAN GRANT: So the
end benefit to users
is that Kubernetes works
the way you expect.
So if you pick up an
off-the-shelf configuration
for a Kubernetes
application or a Helm Chart,
it will work no matter which
Kubernetes flavor you're using.
If you find a tool in the
ecosystem for monitoring
your application or load
balancing or debugging
or CI/CD or whatnot,
it will work
regardless of which Kubernetes
distribution or service--
or multiple services,
increasingly-- you are using.
Because hybrid cloud is reality.
Multi-cloud is a reality.
And it's really Kubernetes
that's enabling that.
Containers give you some
amount of portability.
They let you take--
they separate
operational concerns
from developer concerns.
So you can carry the
same immutable container
image from development
to production
through binary
promotion process.
And they also run on different
Linux operating systems
and in different
cloud environments.
But to make your whole
application deployment work,
you need a lot more
than just that.
You need networking and
load balancing and storage,
for example.
So Kubernetes provides those
additional abstractions
that you need to
get true portability
across the different
environments.
Thanks, Dan.
Yeah.
SAAD ALI: So it sounds like the
conformance program is actually
going to help Kubernetes users
have a consistent, dependable
experience.
So I've been hearing more
and more beyond Kubernetes
about new projects, things
like Istio, Knative.
Can you talk about those and
how they relate to Kubernetes
and how they fit into the
open-source ecosystem?
BRIAN GRANT: Yeah, absolutely.
And Google started
these projects
because Kubernetes
has grown a lot,
and it covers a lot
of surface area.
But we actually do
have a defined scope.
If you look on kubernetes.io,
we have a "What is Kubernetes"
doc that I wrote
a few years ago.
It largely is still
accurate and up to date.
I simplified it after last
year's keynote a little bit.
But really, we have the
same vision for Kubernetes
as we always did,
which is it's a base
platform for managing all kinds
of containerized workloads.
So if you need to have this
additional functionality--
like CI/CD in
particular, there are
lots of different opinions
about how to do that.
I am personally a fan of GitOps
and declarative configuration.
But there are lots of
different workflows
that have to integrate with a
lot of different systems for--
different-sized
organizations, for example,
may have different workloads.
Different types of applications
written in different languages
or different
application frameworks
may benefit from really
highly-tailored developer
workflows.
And actually, it's
getting easier and easier
to build custom developer
workflows on Kubernetes because
of how much it provides
for you out of the box.
Like, task distribution and
execution is a solved problem.
You don't have to
worry about that.
And that's what a
lot of platforms
focused on in the past, and
even a lot of CI/CD systems
and other types
of orchestrators.
But Kubernetes just
does that for you
so you can focus on the
last mile of getting really
a highly-tailored workflow.
So Knative raises
that level higher
by providing a workflow for
these stateless applications,
including things like functions
and arbitrary languages
because it runs containers.
So if you want to use JavaScript
like every functions platform
supports, that's great.
But if you actually
have a Ruby application,
you can run that too.
SAAD ALI: And the idea
would be that Knative
deploys on top of
Kubernetes and gives you
some sort of
serverless framework?
BRIAN GRANT: Yeah, Knative
deploys on top of Kubernetes
and provides some
of the behaviors
that people really expect
in a serverless platform--
like 0 to 1 activation,
for example.
Because it actually
brings in the Istio piece,
which is the service
mesh, which gives you
a lot more observerability and
control over the communication
between the services.
So you know that
a request is being
delivered to an application.
You can then spin up that
application on demand,
as just one example.
And you can
autoscale because you
know the latencies and the
throughputs of the requests
that the application
is receiving.
So that's going to provide
even more opportunities
for automation
than exists today.
And Knative is really
just the start of that.
The one big topic in
Kubernetes right now
is where to take service
discovery and load balancing
into the future.
Kubernetes has some primitives.
Some of them, like
service, have existed
from the very beginning.
But it has some limitations
and has grown organically.
So building Istio
outside of Kubernetes
is what allowed us to really
innovate and experiment
with the service mesh approach
for providing L4 to L7 service
discovery and load balancing
between applications.
It gives you capabilities like
monitoring the request traffic,
controlling the request
traffic, rate-limiting, even
authorizing request
traffic through identity
of the workloads.
So I think one big
challenge for Kubernetes
right now is to figure out,
given the rapid development
and growing popularity
of service mesh,
how do we want to best enable
service mesh in Kubernetes
in the future?
And service mesh is designed to
work not just with Kubernetes,
but also with the VMs
and across environments
and across deployment
mechanisms.
I think that's one of the
real powers about abstraction.
And we want Kubernetes to be
a first-class part of that.
And both Istio and Knative,
speaking of first-class,
have adopted the Kubernetes
resource model as a way
to configure those services.
SAAD ALI: Right, they're
building on top of Kubernetes.
BRIAN GRANT: Yeah, they're
building on-- we looked at that
and said, look, these
systems need a control plane.
Well, we built a control plane.
And the Kubernetes
resource model
is being used by now
hundreds of projects
to automate and control
all kinds of things.
SAAD ALI: So is it fair to say
that Kubernetes is a solid base
to build on, and as
you grow your service
or your application,
you're going
to begin to run into
a set of challenges
that Istio and Knative can
actually help build on top of
and solve for you?
BRIAN GRANT: Yeah,
I think absolutely.
For newer users,
they might even want
to start with Knative,
which provides, for example,
a simple continuous
deployment solution designed
for applications like functions.
You can plug in your
own solution there,
but it provides
one out of the box.
And you can get started
using Knative now.
And then if you need to
run stateful workloads,
you can go right down--
talk about break the glass--
right down to Kubernetes
and run Helm Charts, or
use [INAUDIBLE] on it,
or Terraform, or
Pulumi, or whichever--
or just simple
Kube-control-apply,
which is what I like.
SAAD ALI: That sounds awesome.
If folks who aren't really
familiar with this stuff
want to find out more,
where would they go?
BRIAN GRANT: So for
the Kubernetes project,
there's obviously
kubernetes.io, istio.io,
knative.io to learn
about those projects.
If you want to learn about
how Google is including
these products
into its platform,
we have Containers homepage
on cloud.google.com.
SAAD ALI: OK, that's awesome.
And finally, let's finish
off talking about KubeCon.
What are you most excited
about doing or seeing here?
BRIAN GRANT: Yeah, it's
amazing how KubeCon has grown.
I was at the very
first KubeCon in 2015.
I had a panel on stage with
some of the other old-timers
on the project.
I think it is less
than 500 people.
SAAD ALI: Wow.
BRIAN GRANT: And it's just
amazing to see how much it
has grown and all
the wonderful things
that people tell me that
Kubernetes is doing for them.
So that's really the most
gratifying thing to me,
is for the people who
tell me, wow, this totally
not only made my job better,
but thereby made my life better.
And I'm not doing
all this grudge work,
and it taking us
forever to deploy.
We're actually able to have
much more impact on our business
by deploying much faster.
And it's much less work
for me, so I can actually
spend the time doing
what I want to do.
SAAD ALI: That is awesome.
BRIAN GRANT: So it's
those stories that I love.
SAAD ALI: Cool.
Well, thank you very much
for your time, Brian.
BRIAN GRANT: Yeah.
SAAD ALI: Have a good one.
[MUSIC PLAYING]